if you're a norwegian fan you're tuning
in in large part because of this man
right here the beast from norway now
it's raining mikey lee 2 before here and
mike lilly gonna go down eventually neo
to finish it off and it doesn't look
possible here rain gets three kills
though and now one bullet left the
franchise gets the quad kill are you
kidding me really picks up every single
one
rain was the man you turned to if it was
a 1vx you look to him because he always
seemed to get the job done and it's just
rain left alive he's going to find the
quick kill on to happy but he's got
kiyoshima to contend with what a frag
there coming in from rain he's going to
be pushing into the bomb slide the bomb
is on his back he's got the smoke for
cover so he can make the approach to the
bombsite he does have some time as well
he's going to try to get the frag onto
the viking player the game stands from
this man is unreal there's still two
more players to find though
rain he's gonna get another one fbk goes
down he's created a one-on-one he's got
so much time to use as well he's gonna
make his way back back towards the uh
middle position
he's gonna try to trick his opponent
right now apex though oh my goodness
gracious me reign
match point phase they are on the cusp
of winning this major this is a trophy
that they're destined to lift
guardian weights
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
always happens they made it work clown
nine are your elite major champions
i don't know what happened exactly just
from that moment it just felt like we
were never that that team we used to be
i don't know how much more rain can do
this guy is the glue keeping this team
together even when everything seems lost
so often time and time again five versus
one is not enough to stop rain that is
why he's a bond villain it requires a
lot to take him down down they don't
even know this happening yet fx is
checking from behind oh but they light
all right he shuts down off on that shot
it's an ace to finish the half
oh my god
what's in the places was that this angle
here the rains on because it's so common
for a cd to peek over that smoke there
bonfire goes down rain unbelievable shot
he's gonna double it can he get any more
of course he can it's rain
[Music]
the world of esports is a fluid one
teams rise and fall orgs get bought and
sold and players
come and go in the midst of the chaos
there are a few standout names that
remain as solid and steadfast as the sky
above our heads who no matter what's
happening around them remain right as
rain you have to be really focused when
you play you have to play the game
series and you just have to be versatile
and do stuff that nobody else takes
harvard rain nygard is exactly that type
of player brain's been called out hello
one two three four the norwegian fps
monster has been a fixture of
competitive cs go since the game's
release but rain hasn't simply remained
faithful to counter-strike you see as
faze clan's cs go team's longest lasting
member he's also become a pillar of a
lineup that has gone through multiple
ownership and roster changes over the
years and in the eye of that storm
rain has been indelible
inexorable and inevitable alu can't make
it away calling the heels the strike
comes in for rain
it's like nothing else three kills that
no one could provide but him in this
moment taco
would you dare try and get back into
this
brain's on six hp the flash comes in
taco wants to find him
steps away that one shot and no it's
rain to get four like any
self-respecting european rain's first
love
was soccer he spent his formative years
playing the sport in his hometown in
norway right up until an injury forced
him to quit i always had
like a fire burning through my hip and
it was like at that time that i said
well to myself that
i can't do this anymore and
that's how it all ended young reign
found himself in dire need of a new
hobby and as is the case with a lot of
pros watching his older brother play
counter-strike eventually led to rain
giving the game a try and he loved it so
much so that by the time he turned 19
reign had decided to pursue a career in
professional cs at first reign bounced
between little-known european rosters
and while none of them ever gained any
sort of international recognition it was
obvious that reign performed at a level
that was leaps and bounds above his
peers mbk down to bomb carrier will be
picked off by rain but it's a three on
one reigns gonna be asked to do
something very special which he starts
doing that'll be his hat-trick frag two
headshots into shocks and happy still
only those 22 points of health against a
fully held smith who will
walk away
delivers and he makes it rain frags
reigns stint with a now defunct
norwegian org lgb esports ended when in
may of 2015 he was bought out of the
remainder of his 22-month contract for
an undisclosed sum and signed a deal
with his first ever international roster
team kinguin
now it's raining michele 2v4 here and
mike lilly gonna go down eventually neo
to finish it off and it doesn't look
possible here rain gets three kills
though and now one fully left that
factory gets the quad kill are you
kidding me really picks up every single
one and takes it to overtime that is
unreal the switch allowed rain to rub
shoulders with other cs go players who'd
eventually go on to become household
names like scream and dennis and it was
also a chance to grow and develop as a
player while he adapted to communicating
with teammates who didn't all speak the
same language
solutions
like any new undertaking kinguin had
their share of doubters my friends
my friend they have no chance to be
honest they have no shots
no shots no shots
they can't surprise my friend in single
match but i don't think so they are
ready for win something but no matter
how much hate they got or how wild of an
experiment this international roster was
kinguin were proving that with a few
tweaks and a whole lot of dedication it
was possible to make it work scream's
gonna throw his out as well towards the
same position
he just
relentless with his aggression that's a
double frame it all comes down to one
might find kick
one bullet and a frag secure 13 and that
shouldn't but it did happen and rain
just turns his nose about penta and says
this is our round kinguin's roster
became a bit of a hot commodity and just
four months after the team's formation
they had an offer from g2's founder and
ceo carlos who wanted kinguin to become
part of his growing esports empire now
the move was obviously huge for the team
as a whole but it had a special meaning
for reign you got bought up by g2 yeah
did you do it for the money
yeah i did full time i always wanted to
go full time i wanted that offer came to
the table i took it the newly minted g2
lost scream not long after the transfer
but the rest of the squad including
scream's replacement jkm continued to
perform one of g2's first ever events
under a new banner was the 2015
dreamhack cluj-napoca major and going
into it the team felt confident that
they had what it took to take home the
big prize and it's just rain left alive
he's going to find the quick kill onto
happy but he's got kiyoshima to contend
with what a frag there coming in from
rain he's going to be pushing into the
bomb slide the bomb is on his back he's
got the smoke for cover so he can make
the approach to the bombs fight he does
have some time as well he's going to try
to get the frag onto the viking player
the game stands from this man is unreal
there's still two more players to find
though
rain he's going to get another one fbk
goes down he's created a 101 he's got so
much time to use as well he's going to
make his way back back towards the uh
the middle position
he's gonna try to trick his opponent
right now apex though oh my goodness
gracious me reign is an absolute monster
unfortunately whether it was the stress
of the transition or just tough
competition g2 ended up losing their
bout against team envious before
reaching the finals but as disappointing
as the loss was the team seemed like
they were ready to keep going we can
beat every everything so
we're gonna go to the next major
thinking uh
focus in in the in the title you know
not with the goals going through the
group stage and that kind of things
we're gonna play to do in the majors
unfortunately as it turned out the
team's igl dennis
wasn't gonna stick around after g2's
failed major run and once dennis went
over to fnatic his igling duties
officially fell to none other than reign
who even though he was already doing
most of the calling wasn't exactly
thrilled about the whole thing no one
else wanted to call and i said i could
do it
who's doing it before you michael we had
ligia yeah we had dennis to try and he
didn't want to do it so then like
so you're just kind of put in a role
that you're
not so comfortable with you feel good
like you're good at it but maybe you
don't like it so much i don't feel
really good at it i don't counter anyone
i just
try to make everyone
play their game
but the loss of dennis wasn't even the
biggest change coming down the pipe an
american org faze clan decided to expand
their esports reach and they set their
sights firmly on reign and his teammates
shelling out a whopping seven hundred
thousand dollars to acquire the full
roster from g2 the move though not
without its hiccups marked the beginning
of an era for rain
not long after the acquisition faze went
through some growing pains while trying
to find the perfect combination of
players one iteration of the team in
particular was infamously immortalized
for literally being the fastest to ever
die in a round and now malz looks like
they're gonna be taking the half ahead
keep in mind this map can go t sided oh
no it's the rush up middle eco push just
a year after the most expensive roster
acquisition deal in cs go history went
down faze was a completely different
team of the five former g2 squad members
rain was the only one left the only one
that faze wanted to keep and it was easy
to see why they don't even know this
happening yet fx is checking from behind
oh but they lied all right he shuts down
all four hashtags it's an ace to finish
the half 10-5
or a play but in order to free reign up
to do what reign does best faze needed
to bring in a natural leader and their
answer
was kerrigan face came with an
incredible good offer saying you can
build your own team here there's
only one player we want to be in the lab
in the future and that is rain so we
want to build this team around you and
rain rain and kerrigan are coming
through the connector and flanking in
behind is easy what a stunning headshot
oh my god followed up we're in looking
for more he's almost out of bullets he
gets away left are you kidding me he
picks up the quad kill they're gonna win
the round reign and kerrigan soon found
themselves in pretty illustrious company
with the addition of nico
guardian and olaf meister faze could now
truly be called a super team i mean i
played with rain in so many different
games before that as well and just
playing with me go play with care again
play with guard play with everyone it's
just
so i mean i played against all these
guys for so long it would be fun to like
play with them as well let's push that
position it hasn't been occupied good
timing for rain
all three look for more bye-bye fallen
as well
excuse me
do i say bye-bye i want to go to
guardians name but reign is still in
position what a play to shut them down
taco nowhere to go
that's all five
forces it back olaf tries to pinch her
out all he does is actually open up an
access passion for taco to fall off of
this but he doesn't have the bomb
what a spray on the first three that's
so sick that's all we need to see these
star players stepping up
in high pressure situations got the
ak-47 in his hand and he's looking for
the ace he's not happy with four he
wants to take the entire team and he's
gonna do it what a round from rain while
every player on that team was a legend
in his own right the question on
everyone's mind was whether phase as a
whole could actually live up to the
standards set by its individual parts
and the answer wasn't always clear the
arsenal toward the firebox and hope of a
kill all in one position and guardian
makes it just nicer to find the flash
and nikko fittingly gets the last kill
his face dominate new york in 2017 in
the barclays center all the way through
this tournament they've looked so so
good i'll drop dropping a single map so
far a solid unit a super team of sorts
and inside of every dark cloud comes
rain but inside of that comes rez he
takes down right behind the smoke and
get right closes it
a best of five
against the best in the world
and nip go back-to-back in oakland so
that's a slightly observing observing as
well
guardian taking out one of the aks
actually sunny will trade of course it's
sunny but rain there's no way to check
for him they can't trade either rain of
course four versus two doing more damage
leaving oscar with a ump he's got to
pick up a rifle surely going past the
connector area this is the end of the
line for mouse sports phase after a
massive festive three shut down the
dreams desires of mouse sports and take
the championship
they came into it as the favorites and
finally they prevail but faze's most
important test came in 2018 when the
super squad found themselves facing the
north american underdogs cloud9 into the
grand final of the e-league boston major
by all accounts this should have been
faze's crowning achievement the major
win that would cement them as the
ultimate force in counter-strike this is
the one accolade this is the one
achievement the one milestone that four
of the players on the phase team have
the organization itself within cs one of
the newer organizations it doesn't have
as well this is a trophy that they're
destined to lift but as we all remember
that wasn't what happened at all
guardian waits
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh it's happened they made it work clown
nine are your elite major champions
the loss was a serious blow the major
was one round away from having been
theirs and faze let it slip right
through their fingers
time and time again stewie's on his own
but look at the time look at the time
there's seven seconds of blood
they're trying to build pyramids but
there's no more play
stewie's wondering around we're going to
overtime
while the superstar phase lineup did
stay together initially at some point
it did begin to unravel olafmeister went
on to take a bunch of breaks from
playing competitively kerrigan and
guardian eventually went to different
teams a change rain felt was important
for the overall health of the roster
despite his close personal relationships
with both players it was something the
team needed i think i think we needed
one change wouldn't be enough i think at
this moment we kept changing one player
one player all the time we never felt
like we had a new roster
so two changes was needed new players
were brought in and then replaced in an
effort to recapture that initial magic
but while faze may have been in a state
of flux
reign remains the one constant
unchanging denominator and the threat's
been eliminated
oh my god
what's in the places was that this angle
here the rain's on because it's so
common for a city to peek over that
smoke there bonfire goes down rain
unbelievable shot he's gonna double it
can he get any more of course he can't
it's rain in his personal life 2019 was
the year that rain honored another
commitment after about two years of
dating he proposed to his girlfriend a
ukrainian streamer known on twitch as
sonya the evil and the pair tied the
knot a few months later and in cs go not
even the global pandemic that had turned
the whole world upside down and sent all
esports events online in 2020 could slow
the man down he opts for them and
rightfully so because reigns done it
again rinse and repeat and then some a
quad kill to defend be the round before
and now against the armored pistols it's
exactly the same maybe one better as
somebody's the last one reign will tap
away ace in round 13. push around
eliminates the threat and brings us back
a 4k for rain howie
how has he done that
that is unreal rayne just jiggling
wiggling around and now
leaving it all on to magisk now surely
in a round where rain gets four this
cannot fall apart for faze he has done
all the heavy lifting and now him and
broke you just have to finish the job
matches down with one ray needs the ace
and he's gonna get it and while we
haven't seen stellar results from faze
as a whole during cs go's online era now
that lands have returned along with
reigns favorite igl kerrigan
the team has been doing better than it
has in a long time faze clan they just
need two more and they're off to the
semi-finals the world number one packing
their bags there's no way
exile all the frags he's had this
tournament these
are compulsory for gambit
evades the flash multiple targets
kerrigan slipped the net though and he's
caught on the mantle interest doesn't
have the health for this one hp faze
clan have done it
eliminating gambit in the quarter finals
it's absolutely unbelievable
fun and games
you just can't take the lan out of phase
clan as someone who has seen faze cycle
through countless variations of its
rosters since the team's inception reign
is in a unique position now to judge
just how well they're doing and he feels
more confident in faze's firepower than
ever before the lineup we have now
there's clear worlds i feel like and i
feel like everybody has a purpose in
game it's it's one of the best iteration
of phase even though we haven't shown it
yet i think this lineup has a clear
potential that we haven't really
unleashed in esports there are many
players who burn hot and burn out twice
as fast but rain definitely isn't one of
them for years he has been phases rock
rather than its blazing star and that in
and of itself is a role essential to any
successful roster
by being that ever-present monolithic
force reign created a solid foundation
for a team that has gone through its ups
and downs but never crumbled under the
weight of their circumstances and if his
past record is anything to go by
we can all rest assured that should a
fire arise for faze clan rain will be
there to put it out that's gonna put
rain into an awkward spot cold trying to
cover short he two toppled rain oh
another tap
good night oh my god
phase
win another oh my god
we call those raindrops
yeah the pitter patter the raindrops the
one taps oh man
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock